[Musique]
j'ai le sentiment que dans la société en
cultive l'idée qu'avec la volonté on
peut tout réussir et tous réussir cela
signifierait que l'ensemble de démunis
ont autant de chances de réussir que les
autres pourtant j'ai toujours été
surpris du faible taux de réussite des
personnes venant de quartiers difficiles
en situation précaire ayant moi même
grandi dans les quartiers difficiles
j'ai toujours cru que ma réussite
n'était due qu'à ma volonté
il ya des capacités innées cependant en
analysant mon parcours je remarque
d'autres éléments entrent en jeu
j'aimerais vous demander notre
épanouissement personnel des pentes il
que de nos actes reprenons depuis le
début
donc bon peut-être pas depuis le début
de l'univers on accule temps un tmx mais
au moins à partir de ma naissance toute
logique à ma licence
j'ai autant de chances de réussir que
les autres soit 100%
pourtant je n'en accorde que 40%
pourquoi 40% par rapport aux cartes que
j'ai eu au début de ma vie quelles
étaient ses cartes première carte hln le
souci des hlm c'est de rassembler au
même endroit les personnes avec les
mêmes difficultés
on ne leur offre pas l'opportunité
d'avoir un regard différent sur la
difficulté et se conforte dans l'idée
d'un fatalisme
pourtant les hlm apporte un rapport
superficie prix très intéressants
deuxième carte l'alcoolisme toutes les
classes sociales sont touchées par
l'alcoolisme pas forcément les plus
démunis l'alcoolisme crée des relations
chaotiques entre le parent et l'enfant
le parent ne comprend pas les décisions
aléatoires du parent il a du mal
d'ailleurs à forger son propre caractère
troisième carte
la précarité de l'emploi toujours dans
l'instabilité
l'enfant ne comprends pas pourquoi
certains jours il a tout ce qu'il
souhaite et d'autres jour là des
difficultés à voir un simple repas un
effet papillon de la précarité l'emploi
et l'exclusion sociale l'enfant n'ayant
pas accès aux loisirs des autres enfants
les autres enfants s'en désintéressent
naturellement dernière carte la famille
nombreuse
quand on a l'argent l'envi le temps de
s'occuper de ses enfants
c'est chouette d'ailleurs ça peut créer
même des synergies entre les enfants
à côté de ça qu'on n'a pas le temps et
pas l'argent on finit sur des sur d
éducation très autoritaire où on l'est
on va laisser plus tôt les enfants se
débrouiller tout seul dans la rue
pourtant quand j'étais plus jeune
j'étais heureux ce que je voyais ce que
je vivais me semblait normal malgré
leurs difficultés mes parents ont
toujours souhaité et notre bonheur
seulement il avait à vivre avec leurs
démons et leurs soucis
afin de nous offrir plus de chance mes
parents nous avaient mis moi mes frères
et ma soeur dans une école différente de
celle du quartier dans cette école les
enfants avaient de vraies maisons avec
une vraie famille ainsi qu'un jardin
individuel en général nous on avait un
super espaces verts il était grand mais
il faut voir à quoi il ressemble et est
potentiellement toutes les choses
étranges qui valait mieux pas touchées
afin qu'on puisse avoir des vacances
mes parents nous envoyer chaque année en
famille d'accueil pendant six semaines
c'est à ce moment là que j'ai pris
conscience de ce que c'était que d'yves
dans une vraie famille dans un
environnement sain dans un environnement
où on vous écoute dans un environnement
on est pédagogue avec vous vous explique
les choses à ce moment là une graine a
germé en moi
évidemment c'était sans compter les
aléas de la vie et mon entrée au collège
à ce moment là dans ma famille qui a
implosé avec une île une affaire
familiale qui a fini en justice me suis
retrouvée seule avec mes parents donc
concerne mon père en plus à l'école ça
allait pas trop et j'étais plutôt mal
traités par les autres élèves
avec tous ces problèmes là donc les
études on a du mal à s'y investir du
coup les mauvaises notes ne vous êtes
pas plus j'arrive quand même à m'évader
sur mon ordinateur
mais dans ces moments là les halls les
seules idées qui nous traversent sait se
faire du mal
souhaite faire un massacre heureusement
j'ai croisé une assistante sociale qui a
été à mon écoute et qui m'a permis
d'accéder un environnement plus sain
plus stable ce n'était pas parfait ça
restait un internat il y avait toujours
des relations il fallait faire attention
mais à partir de là j'ai pu me
construire suite à ça j'ai pu rentrer
dans la société et m'épanouir et ainsi
réaliser mon rêve de gosse qui était
juste de fonder une famille d'avoir une
vie paisible
bon il est temps que je vous explique
pourquoi je vais raconter ma vie je
considère que dans notre vie on croise
des points d'inflexion les points
d'inflexion correspondent à tous ces
moments où l'on croise des personnes et
ces personnes vont avoir un impact
significatif sur votre futur ça va
correspondre globalement à des tournants
dans votre vie ils seront soit positif
quand les personnes vont vous aider à
donc les boîtes ils sont dix positif
quand les personnes vont permettre de
regarder vos problèmes différemment
et quand les personnes vont vous aider
vous accompagner à traverser les moments
durs de la vie à côté de ça il va avoir
les points de faction négatif ça va être
les moments où les personnes vont
vouloir que vous croyez aveuglément les
informations qui vous donne tels que
l'effet que ni aux mais il ya aussi les
personnes qui font craint qu'ils vous
font craindre le changement qui souhaite
que vous restez dans votre dans ce cocon
[Musique]
évidemment pour les personnes fragiles
malheureusement elles sont elles ont
tendance à +7 attirés par les points
d'inflexion négatif soit par amour par
innocence ou bien par peur si je
reprends mon parcours
voici mon l'évolution de mes chances
l'évolution de mes chances
d'épanouissement fonction de mon âge à
chaque fois que la courbe augmente en
fait c'est suite à une rencontre sans la
rencontre des personnes clés notre
compréhension et notre vision des choses
reste la même en plus de ma volonté
[Musique]
ma réussite est due aux personnes clés
que j'ai croisé ces personnes ont
influencé mes croyances et plus nos
croyances sont grandes plus loin pour
aller concrètement va retrouver les
agents sociaux tels que les assistants
sociaux
les animateurs de centres les familles
d'accueil mais aussi les professeurs qui
vous permettent de comprendre des
concepts qui vous ont échappé et bien
évidemment des amis qui vont agir par
pur altruisme qui vont vous permettre
d'accéder à des environnements que vous
n'avez pas un des lieux que vous n'avez
pas accés habituellement avec vos
parents tels que la mer à l'opposé on va
retrouver les points d'inflexion
négatives qui peuvent venir de personnes
simplement maladroite ou évidemment de
personnes nocives de façon consciente
mais aussi inconsciente voir dans un
déni total ces personnes là
potentiellement vont chercher à devenir
votre point de référence que vous
dépendez dieu que vous dépendez 2
qui elles vont vous donner elle risque
de vous transmettre leurs échecs et
leurs craintes
dans ces conditions vous faible capacité
ou paraissent normales et in est dans
l'ordre des choses
dans le cas où vous êtes entourés de
beaucoup de points d'inflexion négatif
zabo vous avez beau avoir beaucoup de
volonté vous fatiguer la seule solution
c'est qu'une personne vienne en votre
aide
on vous ouvre une nouvelle porte
concrètement dans les points négatifs on
va retrouver des jeunes comme vous
disent qu'ils sont perdus qui n'ont pas
dead à côté d'eux
évidemment des personnes qui ont rejeté
la société qui ne cherchent que leurs
propres intérêts pour ces personnes
elles peuvent être très dangereuses
qu'elles vont vous mener vers les fléaux
de la société tels que la drogue la
violence gratuite
le vol et toutes les situations
d'exclusion et de sectarisme
la seule solution pour quitter cet
environnement demande un effort très
important voire une disruption de
l'esprit évidemment pas si facile parce
qu'avec nos habitudes on a tendance à
revenir inconsciemment dans nous donne
au confort et au final à retrouver des
personnes qu'on voulait éviter
mais à côté de ça même les personnes qui
sont pas en précarité en situation
précaire qui sont qui semble être bien
protégé ne sont pas l'abri parce que la
rencontre d'un point d'inflexion
négative peut être très violent parce
qu'ils n'ont pas forcément été préparé à
la rencontre des personnes nocives et
des dangers qu'ils apportent
j'aimerais vous demander si réellement
dans la société dans laquelle on vit
les gens en difficulté peuvent
facilement accéder à ces points
d'inflexion positif
cherche-t-on à protéger les enfants dans
un environnement nocif l'environnement
induisant notre état d'esprit est peut
être difficile de remettre en cause cet
état d'esprit de l'identifier voire de
le dépasser
arrêtons de croire et de faire croire
que la volonté suffit pour s'en sortir
pour aller plus loin souciez vous
réellement des conditions de vie de ces
jeunes de quartiers et par extension à
tous les jeunes faisant face à des
difficultés n'hésitez pas à leur donner
confiance mais alors montré que la
société s'intéresse à la jeunesse même
lorsqu'elle est en difficulté
la prochaine fois qu'on voit un jeune en
échec peut-on essayé de lui tendre la
main
potentiellement parmi ces jeunes il y
aura la personne qui découvrira la
téléportation voir l'immortalité
merci
[Applaudissements]